[Musique]
la définition du f elle est là sur la
troisième ligne
[Musique]
il peut supporter le Pérou un perroquet
ah oui ça c'est le c'est le mât c'est le
comment il s'appelle ce main peut
supporter
[Musique]
je viens d'une famille juive d'Algérie
chez nous on ne mange pas cacher les
garçons ne font pas leur bar mitzvah et
il n'y a pas de mezouza à l'entrée de
nos maisons
ma mère Colette 91 ans sa petite sœur
Nicole 88 ans et leur grand frère Roger
98 ans se retrouve tous les après-midi
dans l'appartement parisien de Roger
ensemble il joue ce disputent et échange
des nouvelles de leurs enfants
tous les trois sont nés à Oran ils n'ont
pas toujours été trois il était 4 sur
cette photo manque Albert leur frère
aîné
depuis le début mais on attend de
vérifier d'accord mais elle elle a
vérifié moi je l'ai mis depuis 1h elle a
vérifié
mais je n'ai pas marqué
[Musique]
d'Albert je ne sais presque rien engagé
auprès de la France libre il est mort
sur le champ de bataille en Italie
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
[Musique]
Albert a été enterré en Algérie par
l'armée française il y a 77 ans
Roger ne supporte plus l'idée de laisser
son frère tout seul là-bas aujourd'hui
il a décidé qu'il fallait rapatrier le
cercueil de son frère
Colette et Nicole sont chargés des
formalités administratives elle se lance
avec détermination dans la communication
numérique
deux points de bain un CV
mon frère Albert Lévy soldat français
est enterré au cimetière de La Sénia à
Oran nous voudrions faire rapatrier son
corps en France grâce à votre aide merci
pour tout le renseignements que vous
pourrez nous fournir cordialement
nicolas
envoyez
alors je ne suis pas un robot
ah oui l'adresse email tu peux me la
donner mon adresse et
mon adresse mail c'est quoi
[Rires]
d'accord
peut-être qu'il faut faire le
comment s'appelle le code de l'Algérie
non
ah non c'est pas bien c'est là non non
et là je vais mettre Roger
enlever tout
ah j'ai tout enlevé comment on fait
quand c'est toute cette partie
je vais refaire
[Musique]
Roger s'impatiente déjà mais pour
calbert revienne parmi eux une mise à
jour technologique s'impose pour Colette
[Musique]
je clique
voilà là j'ai ça j'ai une image mais je
sais pas comment la faire avancer tu
sais comment la faire disparaître ou la
faire
d'accord je ne sais pas la faire avancer
je ne sais pas l'arrêter ni l'un ni
l'autre voilà là il m'a dit que c'était
ça mais je sais pas
[Musique]
des feuilles pour te pour t'indiquer les
icônes qui apparaissent et qui peuvent
t'aider
je vois comme multiplier je vois un
petit carré mais
[Musique]
souvent vu ça
les deux verticales blanches
alors pour arrêter comment il dit ici
une fois que la vidéo est lancée ce logo
se transforme en pause pour stopper la
lecture de la vidéo
[Musique]
une fois que la vidéo est lancée ce logo
lequel logo à celui-là se transforme en
pause
je comprends pas que
c'est comme
dans ma tête qui va pas
je ne vois pas perdre vos contacts quels
sont les noms et prénoms de votre père
je vais vous le dire mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous me le
demandez
[Musique]
notre nature est attirée par l'AMB
iguït ah bah c'est dit je sais pas si je
comprends ce que vous voulez dire c'est
que notre nature est ben oui alors moi
je suis vraiment naturel c'est la nature
est attirée par l'ambiguïté je suis un
symbole de de l'ambiguïté mais je
comprends pas du tout pourquoi vous me
demandez les prénoms de mon père
[Musique]
les liseuses les liseuses voilà elles
sont parce qu'il te parle des liseuses
et elles sont là il y en a deux et elles
sont à 99 elles sont elles sont ils en
parlent ici et c'est dans cette poche
99 99
et en plus toi-même tu peux agrandir
autant que tu veux bien sûr ça fait que
tu as au lieu d'avoir toute une ligne tu
as une demi ligne si tu as grandi
beaucoup tu vois
c'est comme les photos tu sais quand on
te montre
[Musique]
tu le tiens demain il y avait l'autre tu
as grandi tu as avec un doigt il suffit
d'un doigt pour agrandir
[Musique]
pendant 70 ans Roger n'a plus parlé de
son frère
Nicole et Colette n'obtiennent toujours
pas de réponse des administrations c'est
daniel le fils de Roger qui vient à la
rescousse
un mois par des chemins détournés Roger
nous a dit aux enfants à tous les notre
générations de cousins là j'aimerais
faire revenir le corps d'Albert on parle
pas dans la journée on parle la nuit tu
sais comment quand il fait quand il fait
nuit il y a plus de lumière on éteint
tout et là et là il parle plus
facilement que dans la journée mais il
parle un peu quoi c'est tellement c'est
un sujet tellement difficile
des fois mais ce qui est nouveau parce
que pendant
enfin moi je l'ai jamais entendu
prononcé le nom d'Albert jusqu'à
oui Roger il a eu des allers-retours qui
sont tout à fait normaux hein en disant
oui oui j'ai envie de le ramener après
en disant ouh là là mais c'est
dérangé
un mort tu vois les le transporter le
tout ça ça va se déjà un moment c'est
dérangeant ça il m'a dit non non on
arrête tout après il m'a dit non non
le lendemain il m'a dit non on le refait
mais même ça c'est quelque chose de
fautif pensez un peu c'est on va c'est
presque il y a du transport voilà
je n'ai pas
vu maintenant
et à refaire des leçons vous avez vos
lunettes vous avez besoin donc ça c'est
ce que vous avez besoin de signer tous
les trois c'est de dire on souhaite on
souhaite nous trois nous souhaitons
faire revenir notre frère
merci de nous aider tata
[Musique]
ça y est
mais cette Albert il était comment
[Musique]
il était musclé il était c'était un
athlète comme on disait à l'époque parce
que il faisait beaucoup de culture
physique
il avait un beau visage
comment dire
un beau visage rond
Albert il était grand il était grand
parce que c'était l'aîné mais il était
grand physiquement il était souvent
torse nu donc je voyais un homme
athlétique il était il avait les cheveux
assez longs et beaucoup plus blond que
les nôtres on avait l'impression qu'il
était blond et qu'il avait un visage
très lisse très très beau très très rond
et surtout parfait
il rêvait de faire des études de
médecine il était très soigneux de son
apparence il avait porté des pantalons
blancs avec le pli bien repassé
souvent c'était moi aussi qui les
repassé il fallait que le plus soit
le rectitude absolue donc c'était
quelqu'un de extrêmement élégant
il n'a jamais posé de problème Albert il
a il a tout fait ce qu'il devait mais il
a jamais embêté les gens il a jamais été
malade même pas rien
à la maison Albert et toi vous faisiez
tout le temps de de la musculation moi
j'ai vécu avec deux comme je sais pas
comme deux effets de beauté grecque tu
vois qui regardait leur beauté qui qui
avait mis qui avait mis à
la rue des tractions sur la barre moi
j'ai vécu dans une espèce de diable
et pour moi mes deux frères c'était de
beauté qui s'occupaient pas tellement de
nous alors que chez nous il y avait
aucune différence entre les filles et
les gars il y avait aucune différence oh
les garçons c'est que les garçons il
nous fait oui je veux dire il n'y avait
pas d'idéologie voilà ce que je veux
dire que les garçons n'ont jamais fait
la mis la table fait la vaisselle
nettoyer rien il laissait leur linge
sale oh c'était nous qui le ramassions
il y avait rien et moi je me rappelle de
cette phrase qui m'est restée sur le
cœur tout le temps ou un jour à midi bon
on demandait je sais pas si manquer le
sel ou je ne sais trop quoi et
automatiquement on m'a dit d'aller le
chercher à la cuisine tu vois c'était
automatique et j'ai dit mais je
comprends pas pourquoi c'est nous qui
faisons tout de se lever de faire la
vaisselle et je ne sais pas qui m'a dit
parce que les hommes ils vont à la
guerre et ça m'intéressait
surtout qu'après c'était d'une gravité
cette phrase mais moi je l'avais entendu
comme ça les hommes ils vont la guerre
les femmes elles font la vaisselle font
et ça c'est une des phrases qui m'est
vous n'avez jamais jamais mis la table
débarrassé
aller faire les courses vous avez fait
pour la maison
attends qu'est-ce que vous avez
qu'est-ce que vous
[Musique]
faisiez
alors on y va oui alors on y va
je te le lis tu me le dites d'accord tu
me le dis que oui je te le dis que tu
sais pas avec la corde
de mon frère
je soussigné Nicole Levy tu vois il me
souligne il me soussigné
donne tout pouvoir
au singulier
tous c'est comme tous au pluriel oui
[Applaudissements]
à la régie communale
j'ai jamais dicté une dictée aussi
difficile et compliqué
communal des pompes funèbres d'Oran
après d'assurer son transfert
son transfert
en France
et imprimé
je vais chercher du papier deux
exemplaires aussi
mais c'est fou elle sait que
l'administration de ce qui est
l'administratif ça t'enlève tout c'est
possible
absolument indispensable mais
l'administration ça existe c'est une
épouvante pour moi mais il y a pas de
quoi être épouvanté
une chose pour moi c'est pas que je
prends c'est que pour moi
de tout le monde
administration ah ben oui bien sûr
c'est intéressant bien sûr non mais
c'est tellement évident on a rien à
faire avec l'administration sauf que des
trucs emmerdant c'est tout
si j'avais pas su le faire par exemple
l'administration j'aurais pas pu je
n'aurais pu avoir accès à rien de tout
ce qu'on a fait par exemple
l'administration c'est la faute de toi
non c'est des deux c'est surtout de la
femme attends comment faire deux ah oui
c'est ça le nombre de
et c'est comme ça que pour sortir
acheter une baguette de pain il faut un
papier c'est la même chose je sais que
c'est obligatoire mais ça ne m'empêche
pas de détester c'est comme ça
[Musique]
Roger me questionne discrètement sur le
retour d'Albert Colette et Nicole main
forme de l'avancée de leur recherche
c'est un travail d'équipe comme au
billard
[Musique]
non non
voilà
je vais me trouver mal
[Rires]
incroyable pas sur pisser de loin c'est
difficile
à 50 cm c'est un exploit c'est
fantastique et un étranger il est allé
plein de billes en plein
oh là là
elle est pas dans l'axe
[Musique]
en regardant la blanche et mes pleins de
billes en plein milieu de la rouge en
haut et pleins de vie
voilà
elle était pas dans l'axe la rouge et ça
fait magnifique oh là là
[Musique]
excuse-moi
pour Colette la tablette c'est du
chinois et je ne suis pas très pédagogue
c'est ena une étudiante en informatique
qui vient l'aider
la question très clairement est-il
possible et permis dans la tradition et
la religion juive de déterrer quelqu'un
pour des raisons essentielles et de le
l'enterrer ailleurs du coup Colette je
vais te dire que Siri tu vois c'est
quand même un robot pas très performant
je trouve pour l'instant donc il
faudrait lui poser une question très
direct et courte d'accord qui
comprennent forcément ils comprendra pas
encore activé mais absolument une
question tout à fait raison
active et je vais aller moi aussi dans
une question stricte
question à Thierry
est-ce que dans la tradition juive il
est permis il est possible de faire
déterrer quelqu'un pour l'enterrer
ailleurs pour des raisons essentielles
voilà est-ce que la tradition juive le
permet
où l'on
[Musique]
fait et le problème de Siri c'est que
comme ta question était trop longue il y
a eu trop d'informations
beaucoup plus comment dire beaucoup plus
général à Syrie alors on va peut-être
taper
loi juive
et enterrement oui très bien
alors je crois que c'est un très long
texte très très long oui
il est très long souvent avec internet
que on te donne la réponse
alors alors
[Musique]
l'exhumation est strictement interdit
quel que soit le temps écoulé sauf pour
transférer les restes d'une personne
provisoirement inhumé auprès de sa
famille ou en Terre sainte lieu de la
Résurrection donc c'est interdit sauf
pour ramener les restes de mon frère
Albert auprès de sa de sa famille qui
est enterré ici à Paris je voudrais
savoir si tu peux me retrouver les
paroles du khadij de la prière qui est
dit quand on fait un enterrement
[Musique]
alors avant la guerre c'était c'était la
fête continue collectez-moi on se
faisait les folles on se fabriquer des
sandales en papier on découpé des
journaux lescendre par la fenêtre on
inventé des jeux incroyables
la maison elle était
elle était banale mais elle était tout à
fait ordinaire elle avait cinq étages et
on était au deuxième on était au
septième étage d'une maison bien solide
à l'époque nous semblait très bonne
vous êtes sur la véranda tout l'été
cette véranda elle donnait sur le
paysage le plus
merveilleux qu'on pouvait voir
[Musique]
le paysage nous appartenait
la vie en famille avant pour coller
témoin c'était le rêve et d'autant plus
qu'on avait deux grands frères que les
autres filles n'avaient pas on avait
deux grands frères c'était notre
richesse nationale familiale mes frères
ne vivaient que dans l'exaltation de la
vie qu'il aurait été offerte mon pied
qu'il aurait été permis
c'était deux frères
magiquement
ensemble je vois pas de votre mot que
inséparables
[Musique]
ou des étrangers aussi
et il te l'envoie par Internet il parle
par ça il te l'envoie tu le trouves sur
ton sur mon internet non mais moi
il te l'envoie là quand même peut-être
qu'il y a des livres qui sont
complètement dans l'actualité aussi oui
mais tu les achètes au lieu de payer 25
tu ne payes 23
ah oui bien sûr
[Musique]
une bonne nouvelle arrive enfin
l'ambassade de France en Algérie va
s'occuper du canalbert et comme dit
Colette l'administration c'est
intéressant
point de vue démarche il va falloir me
transmettre un certain nombre de
documents le permis d'inhumé en France
donné par le maire de la commune dans
lequel le maire de la commune dans
laquelle la réinumation se fera l'acte
de décès d'Albert Lévy si vous l'avez
dans vos archives familiales à défaut je
le demanderai au service de l'état civil
militaire un courrier de votre père ou
de votre temps qui demande en
conformément à l'article
l521-22 du CPM
IVG la restitution du corps de leur
frère auquel devra être joints la
photocopie de la pièce d'identité du
demandeur et un document pouvant le lien
familial entre le demandeur et le départ
et enfin une demande d'exhumation du
super militaire d'Oran et une
procuration à la régie communale
autonome des pompes fun
[Musique]
èbres bonjour
je ne suis pas sûr de comprendre là
il y en a un qui est pour les deux c'est
celui-là celui qui est un gros caractère
[Musique]
ok très bien l'avant on est très bien
on a l'impression de se promener dans
les rues d'Oran c'est vrai on est
entouré de noms familier bien calbert
était enterré trois fois à monter casino
sur le champ de bataille italien puis à
Naples puis au cimetière militaire
d'Oran ses frères et soeurs ont assisté
à aucune de ces funérailles
aujourd'hui Nicole et Colette ont
quelque chose à annoncé à leurs parents
moi que que j'avais refusé de venir
sans le refuser vraiment pour des
cérémonies parce que c'est la cérémonie
qui te plaît pas tellement mais moi
voilà et maintenant je vous demande même
pardon mes chéries je veux vous annoncer
aussi quelque chose je vous avertis
qu'on va vous déplacer mais chéri vous
allez être avec Albert lui non plus on
n'a jamais voulu penser qu'il était mort
on avait peur
c'était une je dis un mot absurde
c'était par délicatesse qu'on ne parlait
pas d'Albert
voilà
tu les vois les deux la tombe des
parents est trop petite pour accueillir
Albert
la famille vient d'acheter un caveau si
place un peu plus loin on va partir tout
droit devant nous ligne 8 donc 17 entre
les palmiers de Byzance là où et les
autres ce grand carré là
en ligne on doit compter le temps
peut-être 9 10
11 12 13
14 15 16 17 1 2 3
4 là où il y en a pas on compte aussi
[Musique]
1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14
16 17 alors c'est ça 17 c'est là où tu
en es toi là
et toi oui
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
Berlin et du vietnamiens
c'est le seul qui a l'air
allô
oui Daniel mon chéri mon chéri mon grand
chéri comment ça va trésor
oui
ouh là là
c'est pas vrai
non là c'est la catastrophe
le certificat de
a le maire de Paris peut nous donner le
OUI OUI
un certificat ou un permis
parce que j'ai noté le permis d'inhumer
on le demande au maire de Paris oui
c'est pas vrai
oh là là mais comment on peut faire ça
on peut pas
ah d'accord
ah oui de débloquer le couper le voilà
le rond qui est de couper le serpent on
coupe la queue on le on les dissocie il
faut le dire le serpent qui se mord la
queue en effet l'Algérie et la France se
renvoie la balle pour savoir qui la
première autorisera l'exhumation
d'Albert car il est enterré dans un
cimetière militaire français sur le
territoire algérien
[Rires]
ah oui six mois peut-être il y a
peut-être 6 mois c'est pas beaucoup pour
une
demande aussi
difficile à exaucer que que ce que
le rappel de d'Albert auprès de nous je
dirais prendra l'avion vers le 1er juin
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il est bleu ou noir celui-là
oui mais ils nous ont dit que les
papiers
il faut à l'encre noire ou bleu
je sais pas si je sais pas
et oui moi j'ai l'impression que du noir
attends je vais prendre ça
là je sais pas peut-être que c'est bleu
regarde regarde Roger
fais plusieurs parties ça
je sais pas si c'est moi en bleu c'est
noir
je vais mouiller un peu pour voir s'il
sorte bleue ou s'il sort rouge
ça a l'air noir on dirait que c'est noir
attends je vois avec un autre
s'il y a une différence
non il y a aucune différence entre les
deux aucune différence
mais je sais même pas si ça existe
encore le bleu je sais même pas si ça
existe
des crayons voilà bleu
ah oui c'est vrai tout à fait regarde
regarde génial que celui-là celui-là il
est génial voilà c'est le sel région on
le met de côté voilà
[Musique]
des morceaux
en 1943 Albert a 21 ans quand il
s'engage dans les corps francs il est
envoyé au front à monter casino
projet et mobilisé quelques mois après
lui il a 20 ans quand il débarque lui
aussi en Italie
[Musique]
parmi les vieux papiers je découvre des
lettres que Roger n'a jamais montré
pendant toute la guerre Albert écrit à
son frère
et c'est fou en même temps qu'elles sont
belles comme il écrit bien quelle beauté
de texte
comment on peut écrire ça sous les
balles
[Musique]
est-il toujours albanova le 12 mars 44
je viens de recevoir ta lettre et tu
toujours à albanova fais attention aux
femmes elles sont toutes malades
on compte dans une forêt d'Olivier en
pleine nature je passe les meilleurs
moments depuis que j'ai débarqué en
Italie notre section à ballon on joue
toute la journée au football ou au
volley comme l'autre jour le docteur a
déclaré que j'étais bâti comme un
Hercule je suis constamment torse nu le
fait est
je suis encore balèze mais cependant
bien moins qu'avant ici c'est au poil au
moral comme au physique je fais le point
je me lave et j'arrange mes affaires et
surtout je me laisse aller au charme du
printemps je n'avais jamais remarqué
qu'il y avait autant de couleurs est-ce
que tu perds à écrire il paraît que
Monsieur le brano a une nouvelle barque
toute neuve qui n'attend que Louisette
ici c'est au poil au moral comme au
physique je fais le point je me lave
j'arrange mes affaires et surtout je me
laisse aller au charme du printemps je
n'avais jamais remarqué qu'il y avait
autant de couleurs est-ce que tu perds
t'a écrit il paraît que Monsieur Lubrano
a une nouvelle marque toute neuve qui
n'attend que nos biceps salut Albert
pourquoi Roger ne nous a jamais montré
ses lettres
c'est curieux
c'est très très curieux je n'arrive pas
quand même on était ses sœurs très si
proche tu vois je comprends pas qu'il ne
les ai pas montrés on aurait réagi quand
même
c'est un mystère Roger est un mystère
en montant mais ton pantalon de bras et
un pantalon de treillis par-dessus
emporte-moi 5 ou 6 jours de chaussettes
et autant de mouchoirs et de quoi laver
sa division vient seulement de monter il
va rester en haut encore au moins 45
jours mais c'est pas vrai mais je savais
pas qu'il avait cette attitude
protectrice et maternelle si tu as
besoin ou même simplement envie de quoi
que ce soit écris moi je te l'enverrai
de suite car je veux que tu me le
promettes je n'ai que ça à faire que de
m'occuper de ce que tu pourrais me
demander
puisque je suis au repos et que je
descends à Naples tous les cinq jours
écrit régulièrement à la maison et très
souvent ne serait-ce que bonjour parce
que avec nous deux ici ils doivent être
plutôt inquiets
c'est terrible
je continuerai une autre fois mais je
peux pas
en somme fais attention à toi pour qu'on
puisse encore s'amuser ensemble
je t'embrasse une fois j'ai pas coutume
salut Albert
je comprends mais Roger n'est pas pu
et tant de difficultés à
vivre après la
mort de son frère
avoir un frère comme ça ils se sont vus
à la guerre en plus c'est incroyable ils
se sont vus dans les
dans les batailles les plus terribles
ils se sont parlés
chacun avait peur pour l'autre
c'est la plus belle lettre
qu'un frère peut écrire à son frère
[Applaudissements]
ah c'est bruit de l'eau
je pourrais m'endormir facilement ah oui
c'est ça me berce
je voudrais l'enregistrer pour pouvoir
dormir quand j'ai l'insomnie tu rêves de
l'appartement d'Oran moi c'est tout
c'est la véranda c'est le palier je rêve
que je sors de la chambre du fond par la
terrasse et oui je reviens vers la
cuisine ah oui je reviens vers la
cuisine et je passe d'une chambre
j'étends le linge sur la sur la véranda
et mais il y a quelques jours j'ai
encore rêvé que j'ai tenté le linge et
que je ramassais le linge Jessica mes
séché
ce qui a été le plus difficile on
n'arrivera à Paris qui était de ne pas
avoir la Méditerranée partout il y avait
une échappée je croyais voir la mer
j'avais des illusions de mer et de
montagne un moment d'inattention je me
disais mais voilà la mer voilà la
montagne c'était la montagne et la mer
[Musique]
on a mis une chape de plomb sur la chose
la plus
bouleversante qui soit arrivée qui nous
soit arrivé c'est-à-dire la mort de
notre frère aîné et pas n'importe quel
mort c'était pas un accident c'est la
mort à la guerre en fait pas son
anniversaire de naissance en fait pas
son anniversaire de mort on fait comme
si de rien n'était
[Applaudissements]
ramenez Albert parmi nous je le ressens
comme la dernière possibilité qui nous
restait d'être
extrêmement humain si je puis dire
voilà c'est la seule chose qu'on peut
faire par rapport à lui c'est la seule
chose presque physique
[Musique]
le premier départ d'Albert ça a été pour
être étudiant à Alger
il a fait toute une année universitaire
et c'est au moment de l'examen qu'il a
été exclu en tant que juif les lois
racistes on a refusé l'entrée à la
Faculté de médecine d'Alger ce qui était
à l'humiliation pour nous
[Musique]
Albert s'engage alors dans les corps
francs il a vu ses deux petites sœurs se
faire exclure de l'école par les lois
pétanistes comme tous les enfants juifs
d'Algérie Nicolas et Colette avaient 9
et 12 ans
celle que j'ai reçu avant-hier
monsieur Levy bonjour la Régie des
pompes funèbres d'Oran vient de nous
proposer que l'exhumation ait lieu le 25
juillet
et que le reliquaire contenant les
restes mortels d'Albert Lévy soit
transféré en France par vol LR Algérie
départ Alger le 27 juillet à 7h du matin
pour une arrivée le même jour à Paris
Charles de Gaulle pourriez-vous me
confirmer rapidement si cela vous
convient je pourrais être sur place
moi-même pour m'assurer que tout se
déroule avec la dignité et le respect du
un soldat mort pour la France
ah non c'est même ces programmé là c'est
la semaine prochaine
Mickaël il va téléphoner à Nicole et
Colette pour leur dire à Port Leucate
non
non non
elle m'ont demandé de le rappeler s'il y
avait des nouvelles
comment tu te sens avec le retour
d'Albert
quand même
l'avenir il est là avec le toute la
famille le premier train
autrement il était isolé le sol pauvre
dans un cimetière militaire il voulait
ça mais pas la solitude éternelle non
c'est l'accompagnement éternel en
famille et par les descendants et pas
toute son histoire
c'était
mais Roger
tu nous a fait connaître Albert
[Musique]
citation à l'ordre de l'armée du premier
classe Albert Lévy
tirailleurs calme et plein d'allant
faisant l'admiration de tous par son
mépris du danger et sa bonne humeur
le 14 mai 1944 à kadito s'est placé sous
un tirage ajusté de mitrailleuse ennemis
pour soigner un camarade blessé devant
Esperia a été mortellement blessé à sa
pièce alors qu'il ouvrait le feu sur une
mitrailleuse ennemi
[Musique]
je vais les voir je vais aller voir la
photo
je la connais bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]